when Forbes puts out these lists then
people pay attention to you so my
children didn't really know the level of
my wealth until Forbes comes out and
publishes and that's true with your
neighbors my neighbors I'm going to this
I'm living the same house now for 35
years or so and people they don't really
know what I do that much and maybe a
little bit but you know one day they may
read the Forbes and say hey this guy's
worth in X billions of dollars and he's
living on taking out his garbage less
like us so uh you know it but in the end
it's like anything in life when you pass
it through you go into the next thing if
you obsess over being it now there are a
couple people who obsess over being on
that list
um you know I won't mention them but
they're they're people who have sued
Forbes for not being on the list uh or
not being high enough on the list but if
you obsess over your numbers you know
it's a mistake you can't confuse your
net worth with your self-worth if you
basically just say I'm worth X dollars
and therefore I'm really great that's a
mistake don't worry about your net worth
worry about what you're really doing
with your life that's much more
important